[Music]
the future is very hard to see where the
world is going and most ideas die and
even really good ideas don't last so
just as an example if you look at the
BlackBerry phone market share you'll see
that they were doing really well for a
while and then they just tanked out why
because they had a good idea which was
the physical keyboard on the phone but
that didn't last they they held on to a
good idea a little bit too long and this
is something that creative companies
need to be aware of all the time is this
constant updating in other words they've
got some great thing that's working but
it's not going to last and they need to
keep updating this is why companies put
out their new and improved models all
the time we're now on the iPhone 10 and
it's gonna keep going because you can't
put out something great and then say
alright I think we're done so the
challenge for companies is that it's
hard to know what's going to stick and
this is because if you do something
that's you know too close to what you've
done before your audience will be bored
if you do something that's too wacky
then no one's going to follow you there
and so companies need to figure out how
to feel out the border of the possible
and this is something that good
companies work on all the time the
solution is to proliferate options the
solution is to put out lots of options
and those options should actually be at
different distances from community
standards just as an example fashion
designers do this all the time they have
their next model of clothing and it's
great it's pretty similar to what came
before and they do whackier and whackier
stuff all the way out to ode couture
where it's not actually intended that
anyone's gonna wear this wacky outfit
but it's a way of feeling out the border
of the possible in the same way car
designers do this so mercedes-benz is
constantly upgrading and updating its
sedans but they also like all car
companies make these concept cars that
are completely wacky so Mercedes
recently put out this thing called the
biome concept car which is the idea
a car that has grown from seeds and the
fuel runs through the car body and the
tires and everything is powered by the
electric by the the solar panel sunroof
at the top and the whole thing is
biodegradable now Mercedes has no plans
to actually build the biome concept car
it only lives on the computer but this
is a way of taking a throw into the far
distance to figure out what's on the
distant horizon to figure out if you can
move in that direction or not and all
good companies have ways of doing that
fisher-price is constantly updating its
its strollers and toys and whatever but
it has also this future of parenting
line where they think about how the you
know they think about the impact of
technology on child rearing of the
future with very wacky things and you
know projected images all around for
your child and so on so you know even a
company like like Lowe's you know they
sell tools and so on that's the standard
stuff but they have this essentially a
holodeck where you step in and you get
to design your room and so on you put on
these VR glasses and you get to see
everything before you buy it they call
this the marriage saver and the you know
this is this is what companies good
companies try to do is cover that
spectrum so they can figure out exactly
what's going to work to pull them into
the future
[Music]